and you said he cheated a lot right or
he cheated a couple of times he wasn't
trying to leave you was he no he still
wanted to get back with me ex that's and
that's the point when when women step
out they're stepping out they they're
going to leave they're going to
leave if he'll have them if the guy if
the guy will have them but when em a man
will have sex with a hole in the wall
like like a men will have sex it doesn't
it doesn't matter it's visually yeah but
they're saying they're not they're not
doing it because they're emotionally
attached to the person they're having
sex with where as woman if a woman's
stepping out it's different she's she's
looking for a better opportunity